je reçois maintenant daniel auteuil pour
mauvaise passe de michel blanc en salles
demain dans les hôtels bonsoir c'est
rare en télé vous avez déclaré qu'est ce
que l'acteur que je suis a à dire pas
grand chose rien à déclarer oui ben oui
nous on est ravi de vous voir vous
témoigner le plaisir qu'on a parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un peu bête de dire
aux gens qu'on les aime mais quand on
vous et à la télé on vous dit ça on n'y
comprend beaucoup de plaisir le voir au
cinéma au théâtre mais je vous crois
alors mauvaise passe pendant nos objets
je n'ai pas à commenter sur ce que vous
venez dire la non non c'est non mais
c'est vrai quand on est acteur c'est
difficile oui c'est ça oui c'est
vraiment fait bon y avait sûrement des
choses à dire aussi comment alors un
espace de demain en salles avec michel
blanc vous connaissiez pas non c'est ce
qui nous a dit hier dans l'émission et
vous avez été touché par le fait qu'il
vous proposant rôle qu'ils auraient pu
interpréter de l'ema bruit si j'ai
trouvé ça cadeau magnifique de la part
d'un acteur parce que je ne savais pas
encore c'est qu'il allait être le relais
le réalisateur qu'il est devenu c'est à
dire que
c'était réellement un cadeau de metteur
en scène c'est à dire offrir un acteur
un rôle comme ça si on est acteur soi
même ça fait bizarre moi je l'aurais pas
fait
et s'est mis derrière la grille sans
jamais devant
et puis je sentais bien que quand on a
commencé à tourner oui que je me suis
mis entièrement à sa disposition pour le
pour le faire aller le plus loin
possible dans son travail de metteur en
scène salle est la première fois qu il
allait diriger sans jouer et apparemment
il avait vraiment des trucs à dire là
dedans le stade lorsque vous réunissez
londres aussi parce que lui nous a
raconté qu'il allait à carnaby street à
l'époque et qu'il allait voir boorman
avec les idées
à l'époque de nemo 83 et vous avez vécu
deux ans à londres pour tourner dans le
spawn de chris bangle yes et alors vous
avez pris le relais à 48 ans oui c'est
ça mais c'est un vieux fantasme au
londres parce que je me souviens dans
les années soixante six tous mes copains
d'avignon ce aller à londres et revenait
avec les cheveux longs les peurs de
risque et c'était l'époque des beatles
ou saturn au stylo et moi j'étais déjà
plus étudiant il était étudiant es et et
quand je suis retourné quand je suis
allé à londres m'installer pour pour
travailler pour le mossad sonne j'avais
l'impression de revivre ce que java de
vivre ce que je n'avais jamais vécu que
j'étais étudiant pour la première fois
de ma vie à londres sauf que tout avait
changé ses talents que vous avez vu
cette pièce de david hare qui s'appelle
la chambre bleue nom que vous jouez en
ce moment sur seine et marne denicourt
adapté par michel blanc mise en scène
par bernard murat alors quand on vous
voit dans le film ce qui est au début on
vous aime vachement parce que vous êtes
faut rappeler à nos amis s'ils n'ont pas
vu l'émission d'hier vous êtes un prof
de français car un prof de lettres
pardon cadrage général qui est un peu
perdu qui s'aperçoit qu'il n'a jamais
décidé de sa vie qu on a toujours tout
imposé qu'il était programmé que vous
arrivez à londres alors au début vous
êtes perdus on a beaucoup de tendresse
pour vous qui vous rencontrer tom qui
lui est escort boy qui vous apprend
qu'ils vous aident vraiment qui vous met
le pied à l'étrier
et puis là vous commencez à y arriver
dans ce lieu et là vous devenez un peu
rires ah c'est moins sympa vous est pris
un grand risque de loris ne pas être
aimée en fait oui mais bon des fois
quand on veut être aimé on ne l'est pas
c'était il fallait absolument si on
voulait raconter le parcours de ce
personnage il fallait absolument de
passer par le moment où il devient con
mais forcément il devient con mais et
mais en même temps c'est pour acquérir
une véritable liberté c'est à dire que
en mentant déjà dans sa vie passée aux
autres et à lui-même il faisait souffrir
les autres et là il s'aperçoit que s'il
veut acquérir cette liberté dont ils
rêvent la vraie liberté
ça passe par une forme de cynisme et
c'est vrai que
et puis on prend ce type au moment où
dans un moment où il disjoncte ouais
mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait oui mais
un moment même plus aller plus haut mais
vachement fin oui c'est rochelle ou
parce qu'il est avec une fille puis
après avec la fille qui est qui liles à
walker joué par kim qui est une [ __ ]
généralement il y avait quelques airs
ville et même chose qu'avec sa femme
donc à un moment ludique mère tu fais ch
est en train de tout [ __ ] en l'air
il fallait prendre le risque et c'est un
rêve et il fallait prendre ce risque là
bas fait mais ce n'était pas tellement
ce qui était intéressant c'est que ce
type acquiert sa liberté qu elle a alors
vous avez 45 films vous commencez vous
avez appris à londres d'ailleurs vous
est pris à un prix pour de los angeles
mais le nommer je n'ai pas eu d'avancée
laisser croire que je l'avais eue c'est
bien on commence à être reconnue
vraiment autant au plan international et
ça nous fait plaisir alors quand on
regarde un peu d'où vous venez votre
famille il faut dire de kaman enfant de
la balle finit jamais c'était dans
l'opéra l'aubrac le plein comique votre
père du chanteur d'une choriste est
alors utile unique comme michel blanc et
alors vous alliez à toutes les tous les
spectacles ont été petit santa maria des
gnons oui peut pas seulement avignon
puisque mes parents donc je faisais des
saisons théâtre il allait jouer un peu
partout en province et mais jeudi
puisque les mercredi c'est lé jeudi se
passe effectivement dans l'est dans les
théâtres à regarder les répétitions et
c'était une espèce de ventre de baleines
dans lequel j'aimerais bien me
reposer où je me sentais très protégé
dans les théâtres sont toujours sentis
très protégé une saison assez silencieux
et puis sur une scène de théâtre aussi
toujours très rien ne peut vous arriver
tout est prévu moi c'est ça qui est bien
dans nos métiers quoi quatre ans vous
étiez déjà dans madame butterfly je ne
fais pas grand chose faisait son fils
oui oui c'est ça c'est ça a été mon
premier contact avec les actrices ivoula
oui c'est à dire que déjà je me souviens
de cette femme qui a fallu plusieurs de
madame butterfly house et les postillons
tous à 6 ans à 6 ans carmen une lancée
de vie de troupe en tournée en cas de
chevaux ces années 60 alors me dit j'ai
retrouvé ça c'est un souvenir formidable
dit la tournée à l'époque de mes parents
et j'ai retrouvé ça quand j'ai fait
godspell pendant deux ans avant la fin
des 60 début des 70's retrouver ces
tests vous êtes l'acteur n'existe qu'en
groupe
j'ai dit ça ouais l'acteur né oui c'est
à dire que je te
oui je veux dire par là simplement que
le one man show c'est pas mon truc et
que ce que j'aime dans le fait de quand
j'étais petit par exemple quand je
jouais tout seul je m'embêtais et j'aime
bien jouer avec plusieurs convois vous
êtes vous êtes toujours peut alors en 68
dont vous êtes un peu en avignon suivent
même maxis voilà mon grand père marc si
vous êtes chez sa fille à lutter avec
gérard gélas c'était un chêne noir
trotskiste ouais voilà c'est tout c'est
de là que ça vient votre côté quand même
un peu une espèce de violence sous
jacente d'un championnat on sent dès
fois au cinéma pas dans le cinéma c'est
au cinéma dès fois on vous voit comme ça
non ça vient pas de là nono la violence
la violence crocs et c'est quelque chose
c'est un état que nous avons tous en
nous et que certains ont la possibilité
de pouvoir exprimer
autrement qu'en étant violent voilà
c'est ça et puis aussi la violence je
trouve dans les dents certains rôles
génère de choses des choses
passionnantes alors vous avez un
accident de voiture à ce moment là mais
alors moi j'ai dit vous avez été
défigurée
c'est peut-être que je disais que
j'étais défiguré j'étais bas c'est à
dire sur le coup quoi ouais ouais alors
c'est ça que vous adonner vous voyez ce
regard un peu parce que des fois vous
avez un regard cinémas zoos et des fois
un regard un peu comme ça comme si vous
regardiez le vide et et puis un sourire
excusez moi mais un demi sourire un peu
de 2000 fou comme ça c'est vrai que ça
vient de l'accident ça c'est des
séquelles à mon avis j'y repensais il ya
quelques neurones coup contre en 2000
mais c'est peut-être pour ça que j'avais
à rentrer dans les rôles vous dites vous
dites souvent je ne joue pas je suis oui
oui oui ben oui c'est à dire que j'aime
bien m'amuser incarner quoi c'est pas
facile que deux alors bon vous avez
jamais été avoué triplé là je vous ai
triplé à quatrième non le bepc à 19 ans
quand même et c'est pour ça qu'il est
très bon pour les sous-doués surtout le
peps fouet alors vous dites et puis un
jour vous monter à paris j'ai moi aussi
je suis partie d'avignon pour monter à
paris un jour donc je comprends sa
visite en se sent incompris alors on a
le courage de monter à paris on à
l'arrivée à paris vous allez rue blanche
concernant drague dans sept recalés
terrible nouvelle et trois fois trois
fois qu'elle est la rue blanche et trois
fois conservatoire et c'est est une
catastrophe c'est une catastrophe
d'abord parce que j'allais à partir de
ce moment là ne pas avoir la sécurité
sociale et je n'avais pas la cantine
j'ai l'air comme ça d'être de plaisanter
mais c'était vraiment quelque chose qui
était très important pour moi à ce
moment là cette espèce de sécurité d'une
école quand on débarque de ces deux
provinces et que
vous n'avez pas les moyens en plus
devenant mais je ne mentionnais
largement non non non mais ça donne en
même temps une force c'est à dire que
huit jours après j'avais du travail
voilà oui alors vous faites d'abord un
concours pour être employé de banque
fait 22 fautes d'orthographes et 12
erreurs de calcul ce qui laisse penser à
nos amis qu'on perd 45 films de qualité
est alors un jour de l'achat lie aux
désespérés pour être machinistes vous
êtes engagé comme figures ont baissé sa
grâce à georges wilson que j'ai harcelé
pendant deux trois jours et qui qui m'a
fait retourner deux mois après on allait
on retournait avignon et je jouais dans
la cour d'honneur du palais des papes
j'étais très fier sauf que bon j'étais
dans un sac et avec les jambes qui
dépassait il aura fallu attendre vingt
ans donc les années 90 pour que j'irai
avec vincent jardin ce grand moment bien
sûr alors là vous avez cette époque
après le tnp aux et s'était pas vous
appelez salut les filles évidemment
quand on regarde la liste des films
c'est un méchoui et vous en avez parlé
le premier il ya pour cent briques t'as
plus rien t'empêches tout le monde de
dormir avec la fameuse affiche les héros
n'ont pas froid aux oreilles et vous
dites c'est un prolongement de l'enfance
à quelque chose vivier ça comme une
espèce de post adolescence oui mais
c'était c'était peut-être même quelque
chose que je n'avais jamais vécu j'avais
pas le temps de vivre tous et toutes ces
choses là parce que à 20 ans j'étais
déjà confronté dans le monde du travail
tout ça est que cette longue longue
longue période de l'adolescence
perpétrés par les films parlent du film
léger comme ça m'a permis d'arriver
voyez aussi les boutiques vous êtes un
truc avec franchement j'étais déjà aussi
bon acteur qu aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque
les films c'était plutôt shulman que
michel blanc mais vous dites j'étais je
te suis pas un acteur qu'aujourd'hui non
mais c'est à dire que toujours au regard
du peu on a toujours tendance à aa quand
on est jeune ça a passé mais
les bilans et quand je regardais faut
deux mois à 16 17 ans j'étais vraiment
très je me dis tu as perdu
l'uni a empêché beaucoup c'est vrai de
deux candidats d'urgence pour le pour le
jeune homme que j'étais peu valables
alors comme vous étiez petit avignon
vous aviez l'accent du jury gelé
toujours parce que dans le golan parole
de l'opposition
quand je parle avec mes parents par
exemple je ne peux pas faire autrement
que de reprendre l'action oui parce que
j'ai août vous a explosé avec une colle
a donc évidemment tout est prévu pour
que lui en fait mais j'ai vu césar du
meilleur acteur il a créé 26 bon après
il ya eu on va tous cités parce qu'ils
aient envie de savoir la reine margot
harry dans le huitième jour lacenaire le
bossu alors vous dites quand vous parlez
de votre vie et c'est là où on voit pas
complètement habité par votre ville je
joue je jouerai je ne sais rien faire
d'autre je fais une chose à la juge une
chose à la fois une vie à la fois sûr
que votre vie vous l'avez dédié
entièrement à la comédie et vous n'avez
pas contrairement à blanc par exemple
qu'à un moment est parti dans la réal
vous vous avez envie de jouer c'est à
dire que comme
jouer est une seconde nature pour moi et
que c'est complètement si vous voulez
jouer et ça fait partie c'est ma vie
quoi c'est pareil que je fais pas de
différence entre le jeu et le et la vie
sauf que ceci près que je sais quand
j'arrête de jouer je veux dire que je ne
confonds pas quand le sait finir est
idiot
mais c'est la même celle c'est la même
mouvance et là c'est la même énergie aux
et 50 ans
ouais 24 janvier 4 janvier chez sun wei
donc non pas ce que vous dites pas
finalement joué c'est le mélange de la
tête et du magma de nos vies c'est ça le
secret de l'acteur est une phrase de
jouve évidemment tout le monde connaît
pas ses 40 membres l'homme je pense que
par l'acteur est donc aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que vous avez à la fois cette
maturité de la cinquantaine c'est
l'homme qui parle
voilà et beaucoup d'enfants c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire qu'il est resté très
enfants espèce de on sent chez vous un
vrai est assez touchant d'ailleurs un
refus vraiment d'être adulte un je ne
sais pas ce refus d'être adulte
je pense que c'est pas bien je pense que
je suis quand même responsable mais
peut-être pas adulte mais responsable
responsable avec vos enfants et
je veux jouer avec une fille au théâtre
vous lui fait un enfant
joue celle emmanuelle béart denicourt
sait à quoi s'en tenir la casting
habitations sur scène oui c'est la
question que vous lui avez posées qu'est
ce que vous faites dans les noirs ouais
je vous le demande parler parce qu'on
est sur une seule émission culturelle
c'est vrai alors vous avez dit quand une
image qui est très jolie vie quand on
est petit comme ça on rend pour jouer
aux cow-boys et aux indiens au rand on
est blessé à mort et puis d'un coup tu
as mais rappelle eddy dany de la table
on se relève en est on n'est plus blessé
à mort donc si vous êtes là dedans pour
moi le jeu c'est ça jouer la comédie
c'est pas plus que ça
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer des
plaintes des mains d'acteurs vachement
extraordinaire et notamment mastroianni
quoi et l'expérience que j'ai eue avec
lui m'a conforté dans dans cette idée là
que que c'est d'abord nous acteurs de
cinéma peut-être tout ce que vous voulez
ce sont des vraiment c'est une place
très très extrêmement privilégié qu'on
n'a pas le droit de se plaindre que
c'est pas si dit que c'est pas si
difficile que ça que ça demande un
effort mais c'est la moindre des choses
est que c'est
c'est vraiment une chance qu'il faut
vraiment
vous dit le jeu m'a souvent paru plus
important que le réel le jeu
le jeu non non non non c'était ça
maintenant je sais pas bien ça non c'est
non non on sent bien non je fais bien
aller je suis pas complètement la
gourmette mamba
je sais quand je joue je sais quand je
vis mais c'est pas les mêmes enjeux
l'accord ne pas plaider déjà vous jouez
pas voilà exactement ça c'est sûr ça
c'est sûr que vous dites est en fait je
vais pas mentir je devient tout rouge et
tout mais sauf quand c'est payé là je
sais que dès que ses papiers où ça ait
pu mentir à la csn d'accord et c'est
vrai que vous lisez pas vous pour garder
une espèce de naïveté intacte vous lisez
pas les scénars vous lisez pas si vous
n'avez pas lu les bouquins de pagnol ne
vient pas lu le bouquin de paul féval
chez les bagnoles cifas espagnol tension
je connaissais quand même pas mal pagnol
je connaissais la levée les films qui
avait vu les films je les ai tous vus
simplement c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
jean de florette c'est un roman que
pagnol a écrit après qu'il ait tourné
manon des sources et c'est vrai que
quand berry m'a appelé il m'a donné le
livre et je me suis arrêté à la
description du moulin dans une flore est
qui fait que je ne savais pas ce que je
ne savais je ne savais pas de quoi moore
et jean de florette et je crains tu
gilles m'a dit on a fait les essais
quand il m'a dit je n'oublie pas que tu
comprends tu es tu responsable de la
mort de deux employés comme j'avais pas
lu savait pas comment je l'avais tué cet
homme donc je me suis imaginé une espèce
de meurtre horrible c'est comme ça que
j'ai dû avoir le rôle si vous parlez
culture vous êtes paresseux mais vous
dites que vous êtes paresseux mais en
fait quand on vit de l'énergie je laisse
ça aux autres 3 quand on voit ce que
vous faites parce que là où là
aujourd'hui vous êtes là tranquille
parce que le tournage du film de benoît
jacquot sa détermination enfin tout à
l'heure de l'être sur scène
vous êtes sur scène avec mariana
30 one donc je veux dire c'est quand
même toute la journée en train de jouer
non je pense que le courage le courage
c'est de l'assumer de faire des choses
qu'on n'a pas envie de faire et qu'on
n'aime pas faire à partir du moment où
on aime ce qu'on fait vous aussi je
rêvais d'un goûter tout le temps on va
partout les jours et à part c'est pas ça
c'est pas un acte de courage
ça ce que ce qui serait difficile je ne
sais pas ce serait de je ne sais pas
quoi je veux même pas imaginer oui voilà
ça mais quand on est tranquille
maintenant on ne sait jamais vous êtes
formidable film je vous le dis nous je
sais pas faire des compliments que c'est
à dire j'ai pas fait fortune en faisant
des contenus je suis mal à faire des
compliments du coup lyon mais elle me la
fait pas j'en fais pas simplement ce que
je peux dire c'est que ce film moi je
les vues et que j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir et que même après pendant là
pendant les jours suivants j'y repense
et c'est une histoire c'est assez forte
très bien réalisé le diable en lumière
et vous êtes formidables voilà c'est
tout ce que je dirai donc ça s'appelle
mauvaise passe ces deux michel blanc
avec daniel auteuil plainte à d'acteurs
anglais formidable merci d'être merci
d'être venus et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux